jean christophe lagarde député de
seine-saint-denis et président de l'udps
et y
[Musique]
bonjour jean christophe lagarde
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france on va
parler de la vaccination obligatoire
préconisée par l'académie de médecine
est ce une bonne solution selon vous non
je ne pense pas qu'il faille rendre la
vaccination obligatoire moi j'ai été un
des premiers à demander qui exista passe
sanitaires pour que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités si vous n'avez pas envie
de vacciner c'est votre droit mais il ya
des contraintes parce que vous mettez en
danger actuellement vous mettez en
danger les autres
si vous êtes vacciné il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on continue à vivre comme si
vous n'étiez pas et donc je passe à
lithaire qui était tant décriée au mois
de décembre il est proposé et enfin
adopté dans l'union européenne d'abord
et puis en france parce que la france a
fini gouvernement français dû finir par
se rendre compte à l'évidence être
vaccinés ce n'est pas la même chose que
de pâles est oui alors le gouvernant qui
défend justement ce nouveau pas
sanitaire qui sera mise en place à
partir du 9 juin un cahier de rappel
numérique qui s'appelle tous antico vide
signal censé permettre vous l'avez dit
un retour à une vie plus normale pour
ceux qui seraient vaccinés voyez ce
qu'on a dit hier cédric au le secrétaire
d'état chargé du numérique
cette réouverture doit être la plus
sécurisée possible pour éviter de devoir
refermer le cahier de rappel avait des
imperfections il y avait un stylo à
manipuler il fallait laisser son numéro
voilà pour le côté pratique vous dites
que chacun doit prendre ses
responsabilités mais ça va devenir
obligatoire sopa sanitaires vous avez
parfaitement le droit d'avoir envie de
d'aller au restaurant comme vous avez
parfaitement le droit de ne pas avoir
envie de conduire quand vous n'avez pas
envie de conduire vous passez pas le
permis de conduire est pas envie d'aller
au restaurant et donc d'avoir un pass
solitaire vous faites pas vacciner c'est
votre droit
vous allez pas empêché les autres de
pouvoir revivre normalement parce qu'ils
ont choisi la vaccination de celle
d'aujourd'hui il ya 23 millions de
français qui ont été vaccinées moins par
une première injection ya zéro mort il
ya plus de cent mille morts par locaux
vides c'est le co vie qui tue pas la
vaccination et l'absence de consentement
à la vaccination ne doit pas empêcher
les français qui ont choisi de faire
confiance en la science de faire
confiance en la médecine
de pouvoir revivre de plus en plus
normalement et d'éviter en cela te faire
en sorte qu' on ne vise pas de
confinement supplémentaires en bloquant
la maladie la seule façon d'éradiquer
maladies telles que celle là c'est
d'ailleurs le cas dans notre histoire
c'est la vaccination on à l'éradiquer la
tuberculose par la vaccination
on a expliqué nombre de maladies qui tu
es qui était génératrice d'épidémie par
la vaccination alors dans le passât lité
on vous dit on va détecter les gens
antico vite c'est pas ça l'essentiel il
ya 23 millions de personnes vaccinées et
a heureusement beaucoup moins de
personnes qui auraient attrapé le
comique même s'il ya eu abus
cent mille morts ça veut dire que
simplement que dedans on peut compter
évidemment les personnes qui contractent
locaux vides alors doit surtout pouvoir
compter celles et ceux qui se font
vacciner enfin la vaccination est
ouverte à tout le monde moi je suis pour
que notamment les jeunes faut vacciner
prioritairement désormais on à protéger
les plus faibles dans un premier temps
mais les jeunes à partir du 15 du vin du
30 juin
pendant deux mois les étudiants ceux qui
sont au lycée ils vont disparaître ils
vont se balader ils vont échanger ils
vont faire la fête parce qu'enfin on va
pouvoir se retrouver bien ça veut dire
que cela doive être vaccinés plus
rapidement possible pour éviter qu'ils
contribuent à la propagation du virus
et eux ils seront très bien servir de la
plus antique au vide alors ce week-end
il y avait un rassemblement qui vaccin
je ne sais pas si vous en avez entendu
parler justement contre ce pas sanitaire
place du trocadéro à paris
plusieurs personnes ont critiqué assez
vertement la politique gouvernementale
dont l'humoriste jean marie bigard qui a
insulté agnès buzyn ah et puis olivier
verront qu'en pensez vous ça ressemble
au devant de dingue ce qui était dit et
est tout simplement indigne infâme et
insupportable assimiler les personnes
qui ne sont pas vaccinés juive de la
seconde guerre mondiale à la déportation
à l'élimination physique par hitler
c'est juste scandaleux dégueulasse c'est
à vomir
pardon mais j'ai été maire de drancy la
ville où son parti 76 mille hommes
femmes et enfants directement à
auschwitz dans les chambres à gaz et les
faux abattoirs je ne crois pas qu'un
seul anti vaccins et été stigmatisée
simplement il faut qu'ils assument leurs
responsabilités ils disent des conneries
contre toute la science nombreux toutes
les évidences contre lens on
le du monde scientifique par en france
partout partout dans le monde
eh bien ils ont le droit d'en dire ils
ont même de droit d'en faire ils n'ont
pas le droit de faire de tels amalgames
parce que c'est parfaitement dégueulasse
et à vos biens ouais c'est ça pose le
problème aussi de la circulation de ce
genre de vidéos sur les réseaux sociaux
quand on sait que que twitter est
assignée justement aujourd'hui en
justice à parlant du salut si vous
permettez
sur ce point un reportage très
intéressant avant les jeux partage
totalement cet habile c'est moi je
communique parfois par twitter d'un
facebook
je ne regarde jamais les réponses je le
dis publiquement je ne regarde jamais
une réponse la somme d'un v6 lité de
crétinerie de bêtises de racisme qu'on
peut y voir et consternant bien sûr
qu'il ya des gens normaux qui utilisent
ces réseaux sociaux pourrait changer
mais quand on lit les réactions on a
l'impression qu'ils sont minoritaires et
quand on lit ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux touchent peu raconte
comme âneries sur à la fois le virus les
médicaments le vaccin on se rend compte
que bien souvent si on n'y prend pas
garde
c'est une entreprise d'abrutissement
général là où ça devrait être quelque
chose qui permet de libérer au contraire
la connaissance et la conscience est là
dessus ceux qui gèrent les réseaux
sociaux qui gagnent des milliards avec
ça devrait faire leur boulot sinon c'est
un outil qui finit par l'abrutissement
collectif on va parler du projet de loi
sur la confiance dans la justice qui a
été adopté hier à l'assemblée ce que
vous l'avez voté non je me suis abstenu
parce que il y a deux dents du bon et du
moins bon c'est juste d'encadrer les
comment dirais-je les enquêtes qui
lumière parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
dérives en la matière avec des enquêtes
qui dure quatre cinq six ans sans que
personne en réalité de sa s'il ya
réellement quelque chose à chercher même
pas les policiers et les magistrats une
forme de pression sur un citoyen qui
n'est pas acceptable n'est pas conforme
à la notion des droits de l'homme
il ya des droits nouveaux qui sont
accordés par exemple à des tenues de
travail doit avoir un contrat de travail
et les droits sociaux ouverts
malheureusement ils sont peu nombreux à
qui on offre cette possibilité
on a renforcé le secret de la défense
mais y'a des choses inquiétantes la
première d'entre elles c'est en
l'occurrence la possibilité de filmer
les procès c'est un procès c'est un
endroit où la justice essaye de
d'établir la vérité de la démontrer puis
ensuite de prononcer un jugement
c'est pas un spectacle c'est pas un lieu
où un gamin avocats doivent venir se
faire de la pub parce que comme y
passera à la télé il gagnera plus
argent ou un magistrat peut faire un
show parce que ça lui permettra
d'obtenir une promotion un procès ça
doit se faire dans la sérénité et très
franchement je compatis beaucoup de
français qui ont été frustrés de ne pas
voir visuellement un procès à des
journalistes on a des dessinateurs qui
nous montre des images ce qui nous
intéresse c'est le fond c'est pas le
spectacle la justice ça peut pas être
inspecteur je pense que ça c'est une
erreur qui est deuxième erreur c'est que
on a des cours d'assises pour créer pour
juger les filles les crimes les plus
graves
eh bien il se trouve on crée à côté des
cours criminel départemental city cour
d'assises une mini cour d'assises dans
les citoyens d'ailleurs sont écartés
très franchement il y avait une
expérience qui était en cours ça fait un
an et demi on devait en tirer le bilan
dans un an et demi on est en train de la
généraliser je craque au lieu d'avoir
des pensées très solennelle très
important très particuliers que sont les
cours d'assises où les citoyens elle
seul endroit dans la justice où ils ont
leurs participer participer on va
généraliser ces cons tribune elle est on
va écarter les citoyens parce que les
cours d'assises donc progressivement
disparaître alors eric dupond moretti a
balayé justement les craintes puisque
maintenant à priori on aura le droit de
filmer ses audiences regarder ce que le
garde des sceaux a répondu justement de
quoi avez vous peur vous préférez ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui sur un certain
nombre de chaînes d'info continue vous
préférez peut-être la désinformation et
le mensonge
vous pensez qu'ils avaient la
désinformation en fait c'est vrai que
les journalistes ont tendance à a
rapporté ce qui s'est dit au cours de
ces audiences est-ce que c'est rapporté
correctement contrairement à ce que dit
le garde des sceaux issus du plan dont
et il n'est pas avare de communication à
travers les journalistes et donc s'il
pense que les journalistes des formes
aimante l'hôtel qu'il faudrait mieux les
qui les ai vite moi je pense que les
journalistes à tort ce qui se passe dans
un tribunal en a parfois des procès qui
dure plusieurs jours où ils nous
racontent les audiences on n'a pas
besoin de voir la mine déconfite du
prévenu la victime en train de pleurer à
la barre mais on n'a pas non plus besoin
d'avoir des avocats médiatique venir
faire du spectacle parce que ça attire
le client que ça leur permet de gagner
de l'argent
on n'a pas besoin de voir un magistrat
ambitieux qui va essayer de démontrer
que il a une force de frappe supérieure
parce qu'ils espéraient promotion la
justice ne doit pas devenir un spectacle
et je pense que là
monsieur dupont moretti se trompent
radicalement la confiance en la justice
ça concerne aussi les féminicides jean
christophe lagarde dans le féminicide
hayange pour le procureur il n'y a pas
eu de dysfonctionnement écoutez le il
n'y a pas eu de dysfonctionnement de la
justice car cet homme n'était pas
judiciairement identifié comme étant un
conjoint violent
s'ils n'avaient pas été identifiés comme
tels ils n'auraient pas reçu un
aménagement de peine au domicile
conjugal
vous pouvez en être sûr alors sans
rentrer dans les détails la haye la
justice et la police se renvoient à
nouveau la balle dans cette affaire
quelle est votre analyse
si procurant de la république dit la
vérité c'est qu'il ya un problème au
niveau de la police puisqu'il plainte
qui a été déposée par la victime et que
la chaîne n'a pas été transmise à la
justice qui est complètement
invraisemblable depuis le mois de
novembre dès le mois de mai sept mois
oui moi ou là la plainte ne serait pas
transmises à la justice dont je ne sais
pas si le dysfonctionnement a eu lieu
dans le domaine judiciaire
je ne sais pas s'il a eu lieu au niveau
de la police que je sais c'est qu'il ya
dysfonctionnement voilà encore une fois
une femme qui se plaint de la violence
de ce criminel et qui finit par mourir
sans que la société des régies c'est ça
qui est scandaleux vous savez
l'essentiel des problèmes de la justice
pour que l'enfant des français puissent
avoir confiance en elle
c'est pas le problème de la loi et
répondent aux dans son titre là dessus
celle qui a été adoptée hier le trend
d'abord que des affaires pénales
un quart des affaires à des affaires
civiles pas des affaires commerciales
les problèmes de la justice française il
est très simple pour pouvoir fonctionner
elle a besoin de plus de moyens
en europe les autres pays européens mais
deux fois plus de moyens
deux fois plus de moyens dans leur
justice par habitant que nous nous
mettons deux fois moins et comme nous
mettons deux fois moins d'argent dans la
zistis on a deux fois moins de justice
que les autres européens
on va parler de cette affaire entre
audrey pulvar et le ministre de
l'intérieur la candidate aux régionales
en ile-de-france a accepté l'invitation
de gérald darmanin après s'être
mutuellement menacés de poursuites
judiciaires regardez j'ai bien vu
l'intention et la main tendue par le
ministre de l'intérieur et je la saisis
je suis contente que gérald darmanin et
entendu mon propos dans son intégralité
qui était le même propos que j'ai
toujours tenu à l'art elle s'est
défendue de
tout racisme généralisée systémique dans
la police c'est ce que gérald darmanin
lui lui reprocher que pensez vous de ce
duel politique est ce que là encore la
justice est instrumentalisée selon vous
écoutez j'ai la pression d'une partie de
ping pong entre les deux ils ont réussi
ainsi à faire la une de l'actualité mais
ça m'intéresse assez peu si ce n'est que
man a pu le voir essayer de se faire une
virginité je rappelle quand même que
c'est une femme qui pourrait prétendre
présider la région ile de france donc je
suis l'élu qui est en pleine dérive
quand elle soutient par exemple des
réunions racialisée c'est à dire la
possibilité d'interdire à certaines
ethnies de venir à une réunion en
l'occurrence des réunions dans les
blancs seraient exclus je ne suis pas
sûr qu'elle soit digne d'être présidente
de la région ile de france parce que en
région ile de france il ya des blancs il
ya des noirs
il ya des maghrébins il ya des
asiatiques et je pense que si elle doit
être président de la région gaudette de
tout le monde
lorsque systématiquement quand on entend
parler c'est pour mettre en cause des
forces de l'ordre qui doivent assumer
leurs responsabilités quand il ya les
erreurs et qui dans l'essentiel de leurs
activités font bien leur boulot et nous
permettent de vivre ensemble ça n'est
pas acceptable lorsque en permanence
elle se met non pas parce que la gauche
avait de beaux c'est à dire un projet
universaliste mais dans un projet
identitaires et communautaristes
madame pulvar est à la faute et
d'ailleurs madame hidalgo qui l'a choisi
comme candidat et bien à la peine de
justifier maintenant son choix parce que
cette vision racialisée ethniciser genre
et de du citoyen celle inverse de
l'émancipation par l'universalisme
voulait par exemple jaurès
je pense que madame pulvar n'a pas
compris la gauche ou pas en tout cas
elle est en train de travailler on va
parler de ce qui s'est passé en
bourgogne il nous reste une minute 1ère
a été tabassé pour avoir fait une simple
remarque à un conducteur de quad qui
roulait trop vite
consternation des élus à l'instar du
maire de dijon regarder consternation et
colère en apprenant l'agression dont a
été victime mon collègue mr 12 jean
claude girard rien ne peut justifier
cette violence
s'attaquer à un maire c'est bafouer les
valeurs de la république
les lâches auteurs de l'agression
doivent être retrouvés et condamnés en
mon nom et au nom des maires de la
métropole
j'apporte tout mon soutien à jean claude
girard et aux zougois
alors c'est pas la première fois qu'un
élu ait visé en scène
ni d'ailleurs la voiture de l'adjointe à
la sécurité de saint denis a été
vandalisée dimanche
on parle beaucoup des violences contre
la police ou les pompiers que faut-il
faire pour protéger davantage les élus
selon vous et c'est la même chose la
semaine dernière d'un projet de loi
justice dont vous parliez
nous avons proposé que les peines soient
durcies pour sanctuariser protéger les
policiers les policiers municipaux les
gendarmes et tous les détenteurs de
l'autorité publique parce que c'est la
même chose
le problème c'est pas un problème
d'insécurité c'est un prêt de défi alors
été heurtée public
lorsqu'un maire un policier un
fonctionnaire municipal en charge d'une
mission de service public intervient
auprès de quelqu'un pour lui dire ce
qu'il doit faire parce que c'est la
collectivité qui demande à ce qu'il le
fasse parce que c'est la règle
collective et ce qui nous permet de
vivre ensemble qui demande à ce qu'il le
fasse
si jamais la personne réagit de façon
insultante outrageante ou violents elle
doit être condamnée beaucoup plus
durement parce que c'est pas comme si on
vous attaque vous et moi en tant
qu'individu non on attaque la société on
attaque la collectivité c'est pas la
république en attaque
un maire ce mr il parlait au nom de la
collectivité communale en dix ans et
dangereuse que vous êtes en train de
faire
eh bien ils avaient tous les citoyens
derrière lui et quand vous vous rebeller
contre la société
vous devez être sanctionné durement il
ya une façon de contester les règles
c'est la démocratie c'est la politique
la violence jamais elle doit être
condamnée et condamné très durement
contre tout défi à l'autorité publique
moi je crois que dans notre pays nous
avons désormais un gros problème avec
l'autorité
on peut débattre de des décisions qui
sont prises mais elles sont prises par
des gens qui sont légitimes à le faire
et à partir de bandes ce moment là on
doit s'y plier s'il faut les changer
c'est dans le débat et dans les
élections c'est pas dans la violence
merci beaucoup jean christophe lagarde
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france